and here's the news from timcast.com
breaking
maxwell found guilty on multiple counts
of sex trafficking underage girls we're
getting demonetized luke take it away
absolutely thank you so much tim this is
why i'm here i've been this is like my
super bowl but it's also a very
important moment since of course we're
experiencing another major cover-up none
of the men who committed abuses here
have been punished there was no deals
there was no leaks this is essentially
the best perfect situation for all the
big players that were involved here
because she goes away she's facing 65
years in jail and they're not giving her
an opportunity to even cut a deal now
there's rumors that she might
potentially try to cut a deal to get
better uh you know a better situations
in in prisons get get sent to a prison
that she wants to be sent to but but the
defense the prosecution is not even
asking for a deal it's not even asking
for names so again there's nothing she
could really negotiate here it's going
to be interesting to see how she's going
to be sentenced guilty of five of six
charges and and again the fact that she
was never offered a deal here is
absolutely huge and this implicates also
a lot of very important people like
prince andrew who of course a jury
found credible to hear out the victims
in this case this means that this civil
suit upcoming with prince andrew which
prince andrew was trying to throw out
prince andrew filed a motion today
specifically saying that because one of
his accusers is living in australia this
has no longer any jurisdiction here in
the united states even though the person
that is accusing him is a united states
citizen that's a motion that's going to
get thrown out of court he's fighting
this the uk police and authorities have
literally destroyed evidence in this
case knowingly and admittedly and these
people i could keep going tim how long
do i got because i could go on for two
hours right now
seriously yes
no but seriously where are all the women
where are they no no where are all the
women in general have we not heard not
the end of me too and everything else
and the one person going down for this
really it's i'm sorry look she's not a
saint i don't have any problem with her
going down for whatever but the point is
what it's the woman it's the it's the
chick the chick that certainly wasn't
doing any of the uh look i'm going to
try and keep it really clean not doing
any of the
yes dastardly
so it's it's her it's the woman she's
going to she's the one that's going to
go down not like i'm sitting here being
like the greatest def i'm hardly the
biggest uh defender of feminism in any
way at all i mean i'm quite anti all
that but but isn't that interesting like
i just have to say where is prince
andrew where well wait no but where's me
too where's where's all the women where
are the women and there's thousands of
them this is another thing i have to
bring up here there's thousands of
children implicated here because after
looking at this data it was over 30 plus
years the fbi was sitting down with the
witnesses interviewing them in the 90s
and they ignored that for about 30 years
remember that the project veritas
revealed i mean i've talked about this
ten times but we've all talked about
this yeah sometimes
yes thanks only to project veritas did
we ever see that clip by the way which
hasn't been revealed in the trial at all
why i don't know well another thing i
just want to bring up really quickly
because because this is very important
the government had an opportunity here
to call in so many powerful people sit
them down and put horrible people away
and now people who have hurt children
and capable of hurting more children and
more children will be hurt because the
government's sitting on their hands when
they have this perfect opportunity to
bring down so many horrible disgusting
human beings but because they're so
powerful they're being given a pass and
that's disgusting here's the here's the
thing you keep going she's she's i'm
sorry tim going she's not a good person
i'm going to stop too but she's she's
not a good person on any on any level
but i'm not i don't i don't stay up at
night worried about her out on the
streets okay it's the powerful people
that you're talking about that frankly
sorry the powerful men that we're
talking about and again i am the last
person to like make that point like
truly but
that's what's happening i'm not i'm not
kept up at night if she's out like the
thing that keeps me up at night is who
else is out doing this stuff like this
is this is this is these these these
networks and this trafficking you think
it's stopping you think it's stopping
because they put her in
no it's not stopping like this was this
was an absolute cover-up i got to say i
got to give credit cernovich is the one
that said this is not a trial this is a
cover-up and he was right i'm sorry he
was right absolutely uh look obviously
he and i are friends but i gotta say the
man was right
and and that's what's so frustrating
about look at this tweet from cernovich
man yeah he said yeah he's he's voted
himself
he quoted himself from july 30th 2020
right the jeffrey epstein files are out
they are horrific and then he responded
today the files were resealed there's no
way to get them again we tried why why
why give us a reason why we can't you
know it's it's him
by the way who helped do this it's him
and bannon that got them out the first
time remember that we're two days before
new year's eve how many people why
they're doing it now last last year at
this time of year our viewership was
massive and there are a lot of people
who are like haha look at cnn and their
viewership no no viewership is down in
general for everybody tucker carlson's
still doing well but his numbers aren't
as high as they were last year when it
was the big election he's not even
reporting right yeah people are taking
this this is this thing i'm sitting here
like a sucker being like we're working
this week
but here's the here's here's what i'm
hoping i'm hoping that enough people
will still share this if you'll talk
about this but i i gotta say man is it
pessimistic of me to say that cernovich
is right this the files are done no it's
covered up it's gone no he's abs i i
would never uh look i i i hate it
sometimes like sometimes when i when i
have to con confront the fact that
cernovich's darker uh predictions are
i've never seen them be wrong so that's
all i'm going to say is i i
when's he been wrong
show me one time he's been wrong this is
the story that makes people see the true
disgusting nature of the state of the
government the fbi here the fbi here
said that they lost the the tapes of of
his uh you know attempt to take his life
in prison the first time the fbi also
during this court proceeding we found
out that under their watch evidence from
jeffrey epstein's safe went missing
after an fbi raid how did the tapes guys
we did all these powerful individuals
lex wexner jean-luc bernay bill gates
kevin spacey so many more i could keep
mentioning here how did those tapes for
of those individuals get lost under the
eyes of the fbi that there is something
extremely horrible happening here yeah
you can't even imagine how bad it gets
because this is only one percent of what
we're seeing there's 99 of what we're
not seeing that's still happening you
think it was only jeffrey epstein's
island no there's five 10 other islands
out there right now but horrible things
happening right now and your tax dollars
are literally paying for the protection
of horrible human beings living life
like they're satanic i hate things i
hate to say this i have to jump in for
one second look that's that's where i i
i sort of connect on this okay like i
haven't been like the biggest like uh
epstein you know
narrator of the whole thing here's the
deal we don't live in the country we
used to think we lived in okay and that
was the point of the movie i made that
is the point of the movies i'm about to
make that's that's what look look i'm
going for mcafee next well you think
there's no connection uh by the way the
reason that mcafee had the word whacked
tattooed on his arm was after what
happened to epstein because he said i'm
never going to kill myself in prison and
look what we're supposed to believe
happened i have to be careful about what
i say here because obviously i'm about
to engage in a big project but but uh
but but but the real thing here is what
you're saying is that this is one thing
this is this is the tip of the iceberg
that those of us plebes got to get an
image of okay and this is this is how
bad it was this is we don't live in the
country we think we do okay and that if
i could i can't say it enough i said it
in the movie oh
sorry i said i wouldn't hit the
microphone then i did i'm just fine
don't throw me out please no i'm not the
first one sorry you're not the first one
i know but i never feed on them i'm
supposed to be a professional like what
the heck uh no but but look that's
that's that's the situation is we we do
not live in these same united states
that we all thought we grew up in this
is not this is not normal there there is
a photo and that came out yeah of all
the binders the evidence it was tagged
and labeled meaning the fbi had had this
for how many years too many too many
years yep so here i think it's i think
it's fairly simple now i don't know
exactly what is to be uncovered what
they're covering up but i'll tell you
this as far as i'm concerned
if the fbi
had evidence on someone who's literally
convicted maxwell has been has been been
convicted of trafficking underage girls
and the fbi had this evidence i could
only assume the fbi and all those
high-ranking officials are involved in
it but tim tim absolutely not only that
but who are they meant to protect i mean
here's the thing here's the thing okay
look here's the thing that i okay i hate
to sound like i'm happy this is
happening but there's certain things
that have been happening in the last two
years where i'm like finally people are
seeing that the fbi is nothing but the
goon squad of the elite okay they're not
there to protect us they are not there
to protect you i hate to i hate to say
this because like at the end of the day
like i actually
believe in all this stuff right like i i
want a real cia i want a real fbi i want
a real national security uh apparatus
because i like the united states right
like i like i liked being a superpower
how crazy am i the point is is that none
of it is real anymore and this the the
the faster people realize the fbi is
absolutely a private security force for
the worst people in the entire world
american or not
the better okay i hate to say it but the
first step is they got to realize it but
just really quickly as the fbi loses the
you know epstein tapes under their watch
they're doing a very important work
going after delta karen and making sure
that she's fined to the fullest extent
of the law for having a little drunken
outrage again thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 pm now don't forget
to smash that like button subscribe to
this channel and if you want more
unfiltered and uncensored content with
all of these guests go to timcast.com
and become a member all of these guests
you know and love in exclusive segments
on our website where we are unrestricted
in what we talk about so you'll
definitely not want to miss it thanks
for hanging out we'll see you all next
time
you